cent ans après la ville d'issoudun
organise plusieurs expositions sur la
présence des soldats américains dans le
berry la dernière en date s'intitule une
ville américaine au pays d'issoudun
elle retrace la vie dans l'es13 quant à
planter en 1917 dans la campagne en très
peu de temps la commune deviendra la
plus grande école de pilotage au monde
catherine lacroix jean philippe attigny
tous les souvenirs toutes les images de
l'exposition viennent de loin d'il ya un
siècle quand en 1917 les forces armées
aériennes ont atterri dans ce coin du
berry de leur passage
il ne reste presque rien puisque leur
formidable installations ont été
démantelés à la fin de la guerre
et pourtant leur présence devait être
impressionnante s'étale sur deux mille
hectares à peu près de caen il ya en
tout 14 caen qui représente ce centre
d'instruction américain d'aviation
dont le cimetière qui est pas compter
comme terrain d'aviation mais donc voilà
donc c'est très très grand et surtout on
a des infrastructures extra moderne des
baraquements en bois pour les hommes et
des hangars pour le matériel par
centaines mais pas que la présence de
8000 hommes nécessitait une
infrastructure à l'américaine très en
avance sur les moeurs de l'époque en b
il ya eu trois châteaux d'eau loin
qu'ils aient plus de 40 m après toutes
les baraques et toutes les installations
nécessaires boulangerie pour faire leur
fameux pain blanc parce qu'il n'était
pas trop adepte du pain noir de chez
nous après il est brûlé il élude du
voyait mme signé avec l'installation
d'une salle de cinéma
une énorme cantine
des bains des douches enfin tout
nécessaire pour la vie quotidienne
aujourd'hui il ne reste de tout ça que
le monument aux morts de volvo 171
américains ont disparu en terre
berrichonne l'essentiel des documents
viennent des états unis notamment pour
les images puisque l'armée documente
énormément son son histoire et son
développement donc voila et mais depuis
cette exposition depuis qu'on reparle de
cette histoire des personnes commencent
à apporter des objets 2018
la france va fêter le centième
anniversaire de la fin de ce conflit qui
grâce à l'entrée en guerre de 4 millions
d'américains en 1917 dont deux millions
de soldats sur le territoire européen
allait redonner espoir aux troupes
exemple et leur permettent d'arracher la
victoire
on part sur place pour retrouver celle
un dps qui vient d'organiser les
retrouvailles entre l'escadron de l' us
air force et la ville d'issoudun
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors en
ce moment des éveilleurs américains sont
dans la commune pourquoi est ce qu'il
aura bien aujourd'hui
eh bien ils viennent tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont entendu parler de tout
ce qu'on a fait pendant une année à
issoudun c'est à dire que toute l'année
2017 on a émaillé mois après mois
semaine après semaine
cette année passé d'événements culturels
officiels
un militaire et puis ils ont vu sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'on se bat qu'on se
mobilise et que le pays d'issoudun se
mobiliser et eux ils fait était
justement ben leur 100e anniversaire
puisque cet escadron a été fondée à
issoudun en 1917 donc ils se sont dit
pourquoi pas joindre l'histoire à
l'agréable et venir faire un petit tour
à un petit tour à issoudun
ils sont donc arrivés à lisier puis ils
repartent dimanche
et pourquoi cette forme de plagiat fait
une forme de pèlerinage vous savez les
oui tout à fait c'est une forme de
pèlerinage vous savez les américains ont
une fibre patriote frites un peu plus
exprimé un peu plus ferventes que les
français et ils ont souhaité en fait
revenir sur les traces de leurs de leur
création
alors c'est comme vous l'avez dit dans
le précédent reportage c'est très
compliqué puisque deux du centre de la
base aérienne du soutien il ne reste
plus grand chose donc on a essayé de
leur faire revivre à travers les
documents de l'exposition mais aussi à
travers un petit voyage sur le terrain
ce que pouvait être cette plus grande
école d'aviation à l'époque on à la 117
pas pourquoi c'est important pour vous
de continuer à faire vivre cette
relation avec les aviateurs américains
alors il ya deux choses d'une part il ya
une histoire locale que globalement tous
les français ont oublié vous savez vous
connaissez le traumatisme qu'a été la
première guerre mondiale c'est une
histoire refoulés on parle notamment de
l'arrivée des amériques pour l'arrivée
des américains en 1917 de débarquement
ou oubliés
et donc il fallait renouer avec cette
histoire y compris au niveau local et
puis c'est aussi un moyen de 2 m de
faire se rencontrer des humains donc de
sortir un peu des préjugés qu'on peut
avoir sur ce que sont les américains
actuellement aux etats unis
non ce ne sont pas tous eu des soutiens
de train pour de sa mairie tic et on
peut avoir quelque chose de plus de plus
humain